hello everyone we're pleased to have you
join us for cardinal health lab exchange
welcome to today's live broadcast from
diagnosis to treatment the story of a
breast cancer patient mike rata me two
special stains I am Brenda Kelly Kim of
ladders and I'll be your moderator for
today's webinar we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by levers and sponsored by
Lika Lika Microsystems is a world leader
in microscopes and scientific
instruments founded as a family business
in the 19th century the company's
history was marked by unparalleled
innovation on its way to becoming a
global enterprise for more information
please visit www em we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this presentation has been approved for
continuing education credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner of the auditorium this will
direct you to the next necessary site
and form needed to receive your credits
this webcast was designed to be
interactive as well and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button the
lower left of the presentation window
will try to answer as many as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem for the green Q&A button
lower left would now like to introduce
today's speaker jennifer burch jennifer
became certified HG in 1994 she has 16
years of experience in various pathology
laboratory roles including general
histology IHC animal research
orthopaedic research and neuropathology
she has held positions at the University
of Rochester as well as Vanderbilt
University Medical Center she's attended
numerous workshops and conducted
lectures at state regional and national
levels within the national society for
histo technology
this birch has several publications in
various industry journals and has served
on the board of directors for NSH from
2008 to 2014 she don't like it in 2009
I'll now turn it over to Jennifer for
her presentation thanks for joining us
and we're talking about diagnosis of
treatment in breast cancer patients
second part of the series I'll go ahead
and say right now that although we've
entitled it Mike Radha me to special
stains there's not going to be a whole
lot actually not really any content is
directly related to special stains
simply because the majority of the
diagnostic tests that we see are falling
under immunohistochemistry these days so
this is more or less just a placeholder
in the process to tell you where we'll
start and stuff our discussions today
but I didn't want to let you know that
right up front we'll review that
objectives that most of you have
probably seen when you registered for
this course but if you didn't hear they
are we're going to talk a little bit
about safety and ergonomics in my craw
t'me and then we'll also talk about some
sectioning tips and when then we'll
cover just a refresher of the basic
chemistry of asiany staining you know so
many of us as Jolanda mentioned have
been doing this for several years as
such as I have we don't necessarily
think of it on a day-to-day basis we get
busy we load the strainer we're making
sure everything's high-quality we don't
really think back to why things work the
way they work so we'll just kind of
brushed over that and do a refresher of
chemistry for H and E and then we'll
look at some slides of a quality H&E
stain at the end we're going to start
off talking by about organ onyx and I
will start by saying that I could do a
three hour talk just on organ Amish in
fact I have done that so this is
definitely a 30,000 foot view of what we
talked about and what we think about
when we think about economics in my craw
to me specifically in the lab and
generally one way to think about
ergonomics as a simple diagram points
out is fitting the task and the
environment to the worker rather than
putting the worker in a situation where
they have to adapt themselves and work
in an area that's not comfortable
for them we're not appropriate and
eventually subject subjecting themselves
to potential injury so our goal is to
not do that and when we think of Argan
ama qui think of four different areas we
think of things we have to look at our
people we have to look at the actual
movements that they're doing we have to
look at the environments in which
they're doing these tasks and then
finally it is very important part of
ergonomics is the alternatives and what
can we do to make things better for
these people and ergonomics the actual
word comes from the Greek meaning work
and laws so we want to find ways to make
people's work suit them better so that
they can do it more safely and more
efficiently and specifically when we're
talking about people some things to
consider are obviously height a
seven-foot tall person in a four foot
tall person are not going to be
comfortable at the same bench and that's
one of the more obvious ones strengths
would be another one some instruments
whether they're older or just by design
may require more force to operate and if
somebody doesn't have a lot of strength
whether it be hand strength or general
strengths that could present a problem
for them and make it challenging
dimension meaning although two people
may be five foot five inches tall one of
them may have significantly longer arms
than the other you no longer torso all
those sorts of things so just looking at
somebody tight and giving them oh you're
tall just sit at the tall bench is
probably not the best idea and of course
disability is there are some things that
just people because of their nature
cannot do and aren't unable to do and we
need to be mindful of that and either
find an alternative actual task or a way
to work around any disabilities a second
we need to look at the movement the
force that's required to do what you're
doing if it's something that's just very
if it's a wheel that's very hard to turn
that's something that we shouldn't just
ignore and keep saying well that's just
how that instrument is you want to just
think about how hard the actual action
is for the person that's doing it number
two is probably one of the biggest ones
and that's repetition the more you do
the same at
over and over again for long periods of
time on a long term basis the more
you're subject to injury because you're
working those same muscles and
specifically the tasks that use small
muscles versus large muscles that leaves
us open for more injury and risk of
potential injury down the road and then
range of motion as humans we are meant
to have so much range of motion in all
of our joints and with a good posture
and once we get out of that zone then we
open up ourselves for potential injury
so we want to be mindful of am I really
meant to be leaning over to the left
stretching as far as I can stretch every
two minutes to reach this that's what we
want to be thinking of in the
environment the first one there is
social and one of the big ones that I
see specifically in histology lab is the
pressure that not even necessarily the
management tells us it's just what we
feel there's 2,000 blocks three people
out sick my kids have a recital tonight
I you know I need to get these blocks on
I'm not going to take a break i'm not
going to go to lunch and i'm just going
to sit here and i'm going to cut all day
that you know that social pressure is
one thing that can really subject us to
potential injury because it becomes too
easy to just do that on a regular basis
and not take care of ourselves and also
the physical conditions if a room is too
cold or too hot you could be
uncomfortable and when you're not
comfortable you tend to mess not
necessarily have your best working
postures and do things in a way that
you're being the most efficient so we
need to look at physical conditions in
the laboratory as well as the obvious
things of countertop heights and that
sort of thing and last but definitely
not least would be the alternatives so
once we've had an ergonomic evaluation
or even an informal one and you find all
these things or where you're going to
need to make changes we need to come up
with different ways to make it better
whether that's different motions like is
there just a different way to do it or
different activities themselves can we
change this task can we take this job
away and put it on an instrument
or you can do something different to
make us not even have to do the activity
anymore and of course equipment as
things age and get older and are
requiring more force or there's new
advances that are ergonomically need to
look at different equipment some more
things specific to mike rata me i
mentioned repetition being the leading
cause of microtome and those sorts of
organ ama canned repetitive motion
musculoskeletal injuries some of the
things that are prone to causing that
would be the course feed wheel which is
the wheel on the left of the manual
microtome which we put in each block in
and we turn that wheel and that is one
we're using small muscles in our hands
at risk to do that often of course the
sectioning hand will we have to turn
that to make our sections and I read
somewhere that people can do as an
average of ten thousand turns a day so
that's a lot that's definitely
repetition cassettes in and out of the
clamp is something that people don't
really think about but if you think if
you have to put the cassette in and you
have to take it out and sometimes
there's a lot of tension on there
because there has to be because we
wanted in there securely so that is
something that if you're just using you
know one finger or two fingers that can
put you at risk for injury picking up
slides using forceps rushes all of those
things we do it hundreds of times in a
day when we're cutting blogs and then
work station design can lead to awkward
postures and movements sometimes you
know all of a sudden oh we need another
workstation and there's nowhere else to
put it so it gets you know set on a
counter somewhere and you're expected to
sit there and cut in awkward postures
and the last one is a big one and
histology labs today we have increased
workload decreasing staff longton that
leads us to longer sessions without a
break and just wanting to get the work
out and do a good job and people tend to
put themselves left and not take mini
breaks or stretching breaks so we're
going to talk to us for a minute about
specifically the sectioning because one
of the most common cancer
turns are things like carpal tunnel
syndrome tendonitis things of the hand
and wrist and I mentioned just briefly
that when we're using just the small
muscles that in our body it makes it
more of a strain and if we're using a
large muscle group at the same time and
the other part of that is we want our
body to be at neutral position or
neutral posture as much as possible not
even at work but in a brass Duritz way
as well so the neutral position of the
wrist would be straight from the elbow
and the arm forward and not to the left
or to the right and this picture or the
man has his hands up and his wrists
event this is definitely not the neutral
position of the wrist nor is this it's
up in the air and so many times we all
attend to put our elbow on the table and
just kind of turn the wheel with our
hand in our wrist and that puts us very
far out of neutral position for our
wrist we want to try to avoid doing that
and we want to cut more like this
neutral position of the wrist you can
see the forearm is straight go right
into the wrist into the hand with no
flexion or extension of the wrist so if
your sectioning manually you want to try
to keep your arm like this gentleman in
the photo or the other option is
automation and this is something that
more and more labs are moving towards as
ergonomics becomes a focus we can't take
everything out and we can take all of
the risk out we have to still put our
blocks in the truck but if we can reduce
the sectioning or the course advanced
wheel and that reduces some of the
strain on our hands and wrists then that
removes one of the risk factors in our
next diagram here we talked specifically
on the top left you'll see if you
imagine this is your workstation you see
each arm has a darker gray zone which is
the primary work zone which overlap in
the middle directly in front of the user
where they overlap is a good place for
all of your up-close work highly
detail-oriented and if you picture
yourself with a microfilm in this space
knowing how large a microtome is you
could very easily depending on your arm
lengths be out of your primary work zone
just turning the wheels so this is why
you see our first bullet
mentions a you or an l-shaped
workstation that helps keep things
closer to your body because what it does
is it moves the user forward and it
takes this range of motion for this arm
and it extends it more so that would get
us more into have us more give you more
area to work in your primary work zone
we also as you see have a secondary work
though and that's for the things that
you don't use as much and then anything
that's back here is what the tertiary
work zone or things you seldomly access
and how many of us because there's 10 of
us lined up on a bench only have three
feet of space to the width but we have a
nice long there could be a long bench
we've got all kinds of stuff sitting
back here that we're reaching for every
two minutes we really want to try to
avoid that so if you could get a URL
shaped workstation that would help and
the second point on here is the height
adjustable surface to accommodate
different users we've seen this more in
new labs that are being designed because
of the importance of ergonomics they
have counters that can be adjusted
higher or lower based on the task and on
the user but I do know that you know in
a majority of labs still today there are
still labs that you know there's
multiple shifts three people with a
using one microtome and that sort of
thing and it's not the easiest to change
the height of the counter or the bench
so that brings us to number three which
is the sturdy adjustable chair to help
with the posture if you can't adjust the
height of the workstation then you need
to look at the chair because our goal
with our posture is to look like we do
over here on the right with our head
neck shoulders spine and pelvis all in a
line with our hips it's essentially a
right angle our knees our ankles and our
elbows all at a right angle that's about
the best posture we can have to be
seated and so if you can't adjust the
counter to get to this point you need to
be able to adjust the chair it needs to
be sturdy and the next point is you need
to use a footrest if your feet don't
touch the floor if you have a higher
counter and you've raised your chair so
that you're in this position you need a
footrest otherwise your feet are not
going to be on the floor and you don't
want to put them under you on the chair
ring like so many of us
because that takes away our right angles
of our ankles our needs and probably our
hips because your plan this is probably
all going to lean forward if you put
your feet on the ring of the chair
finally here to keep yourself as your
neck and shoulders relaxed as much as
possible most of us carry some stress
and our shoulders and neck by nature and
if you're tense then that's going to put
more strain on your muscles and stress
your posture and take mini breaks even
just two minutes to look up looks right
and left doing neck roll just something
to break that position that you've been
in a static posture to give your muscles
a break and again automate if possible
anything you can automate helps reduce
the risk and the wear and tear on your
body this will talk for a moment about
breast tissue sectioning tips I spoke
with some pathologist friends when I was
preparing this talk just to pull them
and see what their most common
complaints were and generally they all
agreed that sections being to stick is a
problem because they have trouble
telling what is true dense chromatin and
nucleoli from just a thick section with
nucleus and it makes it harder to
interpret and it just is not as easy for
them to tell that at a higher power view
of what's going on in the section and
being to spin can also be a problem and
makes it appear that the sane has washed
out but they said that six tends to be
the problem and I personally think that
we tend to err on the side of thickness
because we're cutting fattier tissues so
you know when you're cutting something
fatty if it's fighting with you tend to
bump up the microns a little bit so I
think that's what lends us to ending up
with more sticks and thin type sections
on breasts most of them and pathologist
I know like their sections between four
to six microns for routine breast tissue
and the last point on the slide is
something that we we know in our mind
but we don't necessarily think or talk
about is that what you said on the mic
rata mer is not always what thickness
you will get of the section you know
you've all probably seen thick and thin
section
and that sort of thing and this is why
the historic knowledge is who is
experienced and is used to working with
their particular paraffin in their lab
is just so valuable to the process
because this is the most important point
in the operation to be able to tell the
sickness of the section doesn't have to
be exact but you can look at the section
and tell if something is twice as thick
as it should be or not not as thick as
it should be when it's on the water bath
here and this is why we need quality
astrologists to be able to look at the
section and no well I don't want to pick
this one up is to sin this one's perfect
i'm going to take this one and we give
our pathologists the best possible
section for diagnosis this is another
tip it actually is probably more helpful
in other tissues than in breast but you
can get large dense sections when we're
cutting breasts so I wanted to include
this just for something to be mindful of
the cutting force when we're cutting if
you think about it the block comes down
on to the microtel blade so the force is
coming from the bottom of the block and
moving upwards and with that in mind if
you put the Block in vertically as this
first picture does here you're clamping
surfaces are going to be the bottom
which is straight and then the
small-angle top portion of the top so
they're not exactly the same and this
portion is not quite as stable it's
still stable and mind you i know that
you know you're probably all thinking oh
I always cut like that lots of places do
but if you're having trouble something
that you can try is to turn it sideways
and have two parallel even square
surfaces for clamping that can give you
a more stable clamp if you're having
thick incident or vibrations with larger
dense tissues just try turning it that
way sometimes that will help again
that's you know usually more helpful
with bone or something that's harder but
it can be effective for breast tissue
and we'll talk just a reminder of some
of the things that can affect the
quality of our sections the sickness and
the quality both can depend on all of
these things temperature over the room
and the block the thickness of the
trimming the angle of the blade
depending on the paraffin some paraffins
have different polymer mixes
and the compression can be greater or
lesser depending on another paraffin and
then of course the sectioning speed
we'll talk a little bit about Romans
love temperature most of us have
experienced what it's like if the room
gets a little too hot the paraffin
doesn't like to cut the cool room is
ideal for the paraffin to cut and the
optimum temperature depends really on
the embedding media and on the tissue
and when we the reason that we chill
tissue blocks to make them holder is
because it makes the tissue and the wax
homogeneous and it cuts better when they
are more of the same consistency than a
soft warm wax and a hard piece of tissue
and when we use warm water that was
often the specimen and although we don't
really use it with breast tissues
sometimes we can if there's a piece of
that has a lot of calcification or have
been a little bit over processed we can
use the warm water on the breast blocks
just like we do on the GIS and the other
samples in the lab the preferred way of
chilling blocks is with moist ice it
gives you both some water to hydrate and
the cool and we like to say that you
should avoid chilling the blog with the
aerosol coolant just because it's easy
to overdo it and then you get a cracked
block and cracked issue but if you do
use a cooling spray which I know a lot
of people do use short bursts to present
to prevent cracking of the block smoking
of the block and this is something again
that we don't really do a lot of with
breast tissue but we can so just touch
on it and remind ourselves of why we do
that and it's mainly to restore restore
moisture to over dehydrated specimens
breast tissue being primarily fatty
tissue by Nature doesn't necessarily
need soap as much as some others issues
but if you give it brief exposure to
water and ice then you'll rehydrate the
next few sections of course if you soak
it too long then you're going to expand
the cut surface of the block and then
you can lose tissue because the tissue
will swell and when you look at the
block your tissue will actually be
protruding out further than the wax so
when you start to cut you're going to be
getting tissue instead of wax
for a while so we want to be mindful of
that and not expose it to water for too
long and then the last one on here
proper processing obviously is the key
and you we've learned about that in the
first installment of this series and one
thing I will say with breast tissue in
particular with the strict guidelines
that for our processing and fixation for
IHC we really don't see in my opinion
from what I want to talk to different
labs we don't see the wild variation
that we do with some other tissues
because people can only tweak the
fixation portion and the processing so
much because they have to stay within
the parameters of those guidelines which
I think those were addressed in the
first series and they'll probably be
talked about more in the I HD series so
I'm not going to get into that but it is
something that you really don't see as
much variation in breast tissue as you
do in the other tissues in our lab that
don't have such stringent guidelines
across the board and that of course
reduces the need to soak or do any
remedying if we have proper processing
in the first place the next one is
trimming sickness and this is something
that most of us don't think of affecting
our sections in our mind we're thinking
I'm throwing all these sections away so
I can go as fast as I want instead of
istic if I want and I'm just going to go
too crazy but aggressive spearmint a
trimming makes a muscle effect which you
may have seen on the subsequent sections
and it can vary with how far into the
block it goes with breast tissue tending
to be soft the moth hole effect can go
in several sections and so that's
something we want to be mindful of and
something that i just recently learned
is that the appearance of tightly rolled
up sections when you're trimming can
mean that you're trimming too thick if
they're very very tight little rolls
then you're likely trimming too thick
and that's whether you're doing the
old-fashioned as i call it rocking
technique or using a trim function and
just setting your my Cronkite or higher
and rotating this sectioning wheel
either way you can get those tightly
rolled up sections and that means your
sectioning to sick and then large
samples you really should trim in the
sinner and slower because you want to
just be mindful not
chungking out best specimens and even
with breath you know if we get one that
has a calcification and it's large and
still almost the whole because that you
don't want to be trimming in really
rapid and stick because you can lose
that tissue and ideally you want to do
trimming at 30 to 50 microns less if you
can get away with it the sectioning
thickness and speed is one that we are
more mindful of because these are the
actual sections we're going to collect
and the rate at which we cut will
directly affect the thickness and the
quality and if you cut too fast you will
invariably compromise the quality of the
section maybe not every time but you
leave yourself open to more variability
the faster you go when you cut too fast
that we're creating heat because of the
friction of the block going over that
blade so frequently we're warming up the
block space and the sections become
thicker and it may not even be that you
notice it because you aren't going so
fast and you're only taking four
sections but they will get sicker as
they get warmer because the paraffin
likes to cut one is cold and some other
things that excessive speed can cause
would be compression thickens in
venetian blind and that's largely
because extreme speed cutting it can
cause a lot of vibration in the blade
holder and even in our block holder and
that gives us some variation in our
sectioning so now we'll review the
chemistry of asiany and again this is
another thing we could talk about
different H&E stains and things of how
they work all day long but in the
interest of time this is just a little
refresher and maybe we'll think of some
things we haven't thought of in a while
the paraffin ization of course we start
out with tissues that are in wax we want
to put them in a dye and we ultimately
want to have them able to pass light
through and be evaluated by the
pathologist so we need to get the wax
out and we do that with with xylene
traditionally there are substitutes out
there that do a great job that are a
little more environmentally user
friendly than xylene if you're using
xylene you can usually get away with
three changes for one to two minutes the
substitutes generally are more gentle
and needle
one more time we want to make sure we
get all the wax out of there if we leave
wax in our sections will have
variability in our staining and our
pathologist won't be able to make the
diagnosis and one thing that I think is
important in today's fast-paced
histology lab is to be able to come in
if sustainer in his crash and take the
sections out and look at them and say
okay where would the section in the
process if you can't tell electronically
to look at the section and know so at
this stage the sections will be clear
and that has to do with the refractive
index of xylene and the other clearance
it's the same it's similar to that of
the protein in our tissues so after we
go through that they will appear clear
at this point instead of white as they
were when we put them on the saner or in
our hand staining so after we've gotten
out the wax we need to hydrate this
issue because our primary nuclear diet
hematoxylin is aqueous so we need to
have an aqueous environment for that
human Sox went to work appropriately we
want to get that water out so we go
through one hundred percent alcohol to
get the xylene or the substitute out of
the tissues and then we go through
graded water to gradually put water back
a grated alcohols to gradually put the
water back in and that varies from place
to place depending on your tissue type
and you know you're stating protocol
some people don't use a 70 generally the
more gradual of the grading the more
gentle it is on your tissues if you work
for example go from xylene to 100% to
running water to human Tok Celyn you
would likely lose a lot of tissue
because that's just harsh on the tissue
you're putting your more or less
shocking the tissue and all if you
remember we just have a piece of tissue
on a glass slide so the gradual grading
of the alcohol is gentle on the tissue
and helped us introduce the water with
less loss of tissue happening and then
we do a running water steps to get all
the alcohol out of there because again
we want to get to an aqueous state for
the pneumococcus one now will actually
talk about human toxin for a little bit
hematoxylin is the oxidized product of
hematin which is a natural dye by itself
it doesn't really have affinity for
staining if you just had plain
hematoxylin powder
it will stay in a little bit but not the
way we wanted to is our main nuclear
died so we combine it with metallic
salts which are more dense and that
reacts with the Seine and it forms an
insoluble precipitate if you don't have
the mordant it won't connect the dye to
the tissue the way it does in our stains
so we need that Morton hematoxylin is
widely known as one of the best nuclear
scenes there's a few main types that
will just touch on briefly Harrison
mayor are two of the most common and
those continue to oxidize and should be
filtered no I do know that there are
commercial preparations out there that
have been able to be formulated that you
don't need to filter them if you're
changing them often so I know you may be
thinking why use a Harris and I don't
have to filter it obviously if you saw
precipitate you would filter it but
there are commercial preparations out
there that do not need to be filtered
even though they are a Harrison and
Mayor and then the last one on here is
gills which oxidizes very slowly and
generally doesn't need filtering it's a
good choice for labs that are low volume
and want to get a lot of use out of
there but don't really want to feel
tilted their human talks one everyday
yields commonly used their the chemistry
of human toxin it's a basic die it
carries a positive charge so that's why
it's attracted to the negative charges
of the chromatin within our nuclear in
the nucleus which is the DNA in the RNA
so we have the positive charge of the
dye attracted to the negative charge of
the nucleus and that's what makes it
such a strong nuclear nuclear stain and
there are also covalent bonds which are
strong and here's just a little diagram
of a covalent bond versus an ionic bond
and you see over here in the covalent
bond when we're sharing electrons how
much is overlaps and this is just a
brief description of how strong the
covalent bond can be and that's one of
their many reasons why hematoxylin is
such a good nuclear stain traditional
staining methods will talk about the
regressive method first so in regressive
saying you're going to over stained with
hematoxylin the harris is the most
common we've seen everything and we if
it was if we rinse it it's not going to
rinse off that's the way we've
overstayed it is going to stay that way
until we do something about it so after
we wash we need to put it in a mild s
and silly
it's going to take out the excess
hematoxylin so ideally you're
overstating everything and then you're
going to take out what you don't want
and that's why people you know once
you've found yours dating protocol for
your facility you generally don't make
major changes to it if you're using a
regressive standing method because you
found just what pulls out enough pain to
get to the desired standing intensity
and then we need to wash to get that
acid out of there so we'll go through a
wash step and we need to put them in
bluing after that because they're going
to be reddish purplish color after we go
in the acid and we need to get them back
to the blue the blue or purple color
that the pathologist is used to seeing
we're going to take just a little break
here and talk specifically about
differentiation and gluing so in theory
differentiation is when the acid alcohol
attacks the tissue mordant and a diet
mordant I linkages that we made and we
made those inside the insoluble
connections we put the acid into that
equation it unlinked that and that's
what able enables us to get out the
excess hematoxylin that we don't want in
parts of our tissue but then we need to
be mindful of when we put it in the acid
pH that human sin when it becomes
soluble it also becomes red and so the
sections are a reddish purplish kind of
color and the pathologist won't be
really happy if we give him those to
diagnose and that's why we use a bluing
reagent at this point and that's usually
an alkaline solution olivium something
like that because when we're at an
alkaline pH the mordant dilaik reforms
again so that we again have an insoluble
blue color and what was an overstaying
dark purple site now it's the nice crisp
blue purple color that we want for our
nuclei and then in a progressive method
is guild is the most common hematoxylin
used for that we're going to selectively
stain the nuclear material so we're only
going to stain it as dark and is intense
as we want to see we're not going to
over stain and then you don't have to
use and acid alcohol I will say that I
know a lot of people use a very dilute
acid alcohol even in their progressive
staying and that's primarily
clean up extraneous stain it might be on
the slide it's not a d staining so to
speak but if you have ever noticed a
purple sheet on your slides when they
come out of human toxin that can happen
with gills and so some people will
quickly use just a brief dip in an asset
alcohol and it's usually more dilute and
weaker than what we would use in a
redress of stain but in case you're just
looking at my two bullets and saying
well I know why you guilt and I know I
do a dip in alcohol that's generally why
it's usually just to clean up any
background stain and not necessarily 2d
stay in your tissue and then after the
human talks went in Gill slides are
washed and then generally put in bluing
to deepen the blue purple color
generally washing them in running water
long enough wood blue them but most of
us don't have that kind of time so we
use a bluing reagent and progressive
staining as well of course after that we
need our counterstain and we're going to
talk about eosin and our HD counter
stains in general are secondary dives
that enhance the visibility of the
primary die without obscuring it so if
you think about the things that we use
in histology today as some sex some
counterstained nuclear fats red met no
yellow fast green those sorts of things
are all more gentle light colors that
when put with the primary die enhance it
but don't distract from it and if you've
ever done a stain in your counterstain
doesn't work of any kind whether it's in
iron stain or orang H&E even though the
primary stains still stands as it always
had it can markedly change the
appearance of your staying over all so
that's so it's so important to how our
counter stains at the right intensity
because our pathologists are used to
looking at a certain balance of the
primary stain and the counter stand we
want to make sure that we give them that
that same balance as often as possible
so eosin is usually typic is typically
typically an alcoholic formulation so
once we come out of bluing we need to
get back to an alcoholic state because
again it's easier for our tissue if
everything if we go from likes to like
so we want to go back into alcohol
like state and we usually do that with a
rinse in 95 before we go into the ESN
there are aqueous solutions of ESN out
there and if you're using one of those
you don't need to go into 95 first but
the majority of them are usually
alcoholic so we would go through 95 and
into Gibson but both ET a-- sins that
are alcoholic and aqueous worked very
well so whichever you're using is
totally fine and you should stick with
it and then we talked a little bit about
the chemistry of the human toxin and
then so when we think about eosin its
acidic and it has a negative charge and
it has affinity to the cytoplasm so
that's the reason why it stands i
cytoplasm so well so after we've got all
of our dives on we are going to
dehydrate and this is again because
we're talking about getting to a point
where we can permanently mount this
section for diagnosis and archival and
we need to get the water out of there
and so and we need to get the out they
are the alcohol out of there so we go
through a series of alcohol from 95 into
one hundred percent some people do like
more of the one hundred percent under 95
and that's generally because we want to
make sure that the one hundred percent
is absolutely one hundred percent
because it can cause problems if there's
still water lingering in there
especially if you're using a xylene
substitute dialing substitutes are
generally not forgiving you all of water
content xylene itself doesn't like water
but xylene substitutes are much more
finicky about that and something that's
important to be mindful livid you may
not even notice a problem right away you
may cover slip your slides and they may
look fine but if there was water in
there that was not removed because the
one hundred percent for it clean you can
find problems weeks to months later you
can find your tissue is starting to fade
or the e essence bleeding out and it
generally comes from not enough
dehydration and having water in there
when we covers with those slides and
then we just want to make sure we again
rotate and change frequently to make
sure that all the water is removed and
we're using true absolutes at the ends
then we're going to clear our side
slides we're going to use xylene or
substitute because those are what are
miscible with our permanent mountains
which is our end goal here and so the
gut again we talked about it earlier
that the xylene renders the tissue clear
and transparent due to the refractive
index being similar to the protein in
the tissues and what we want is for the
pathologist to be able to easily pass
light through our section and evaluate
our tissue components that we obtained
so we want our tissue to be cleared some
people I read call it d Alko alcohol
ovation agents I don't call it that
because I can barely pronounce that but
that is if you hear somebody say that
they're talking about clearing agents
and they are if we're not going to
permanently mount it for the frozen
section and we don't want to then we
will not clear you can go from water to
an a great aqueous mounted and not need
to go through clearing but for general
routine staining and archival we're
going to go through the clearing step
okay so now we're going to look at some
slides and we'll start this section by
saying I am NOT a pathologist but I did
take some slides for us of some normal
and a few of breast cancer to just show
you how important our good sectioning
and staining is to the process and just
remind ourselves as the beautiful work
that we do and just I'm going to touch
on just a little bit of some structures
and that sort of thing but it's
definitely not an all encompassing
discussion of these things and you'll
get more of this in the next in this
series so when you think about the
breast the breast has a branching system
of ducks that lead down from the nipple
there's approximately 12 large ducks
that emerge from the breast as
lactiferous ducts and those ducks branch
repeatedly in ultimately form what's
called the terminal ducts lobular units
and that's what we're looking at on our
slide here the tissue between the ducts
in the glands which is the bulk of the
volume of the adult breast is composed
of fat and fiber tissue and that varies
in proportions
based on different things such as
hormones and just the person in general
and the generic name given to everything
that is in between the glands is called
stroma you've probably heard that term
before stroma in any organ is
essentially the connective tissue
framework that doesn't perform the
function of the organ so in this case
the function of the breast being to
produce milk for the infant's the stroma
is the connective tissue framework that
doesn't perform that function so when we
look at this we see our glands and then
we see our stroma so that's the general
normal tissue here the again the amount
of glandular tissue is dependent on
hormonal activity and can fluctuate with
the menstrual cycle and then with or
with pregnancy or with age the ducks and
the glands are lined you can see in the
higher power picture on the bottom they
are aligned by two layers of epithelium
which is supported by a basement
membrane most of these are the breast
affect the ducks and the glands and
carcinomas arrived from the epithelial
cells that line the structures that's
what we are looking at down here I don't
know how well far even can zoom in but
they we can see the epithelial cells
lining the glands here so this is a
slide from a normal breast in late
pregnancy so you can see the expansion
of the TDL use you can see that the
epithelium starts to accumulate some fat
droplets over here you can see that
there's some vacuoles in the cytoplasm
of the cells and then that it looks like
the non-specialized stroma has
diminished and that's because of the
expansion of the TDL youth are taking up
more of the space and they're crowding
the tissue and this is again this is
normal and this is the late pregnancy so
by contrast to that we also have a slide
from postmenopausal so this is a lobule
that if set in non-specialized stroma
and you see over just a general
reduction in
Angela tissue and relatively increase
stroma in the epithelial the
myoepithelial cells are smaller and
there can be areas of fibrosis and can
also see benign calcifications although
we don't really see them in this section
but you can just see the market
difference between normal premenopausal
and postmenopausal in the gland versus
stroma and this is a good disk slide
here is a good indicator of a nice eosin
stain relief evident in our stroma so
the next slide is benign
microcalcifications the actual diagnosis
of this core biopsy was epic rin
metaplasia and what that means is that
the glands the epithelium starts to
resemble sweat glands and up here you
can see they kind of look like you see
sweat glands this is commonly seen in
fibrocystic disease of the breasts and
these are phosphate microcalcifications
right here and otisco text I know the
majority of you looked at this and you
all saw the knife mark and that's when
you thought about what it would be like
to cut this tissue that's generally the
difference if you sit down with a
pathologist look at a slide of the
histor technologists looking at it
versus the pathologist our first thought
is to look into the knife marks and
there you know seeing the apocrine
metaplasia and but this is just to show
you the staining and when we do have any
kind of calcification like that they
tend to be very dark and very dense and
again we can see just the nuclear
details very good in our staining so
even though we have nice more except
somewhat to be expected when we have
those calcifications and again that was
benign so now we'll do a few slides of
some cancers we're going to talk a
little bit about low-grade ductal
carcinoma in situ DCIS means that the
cancer is confined within the ducks it's
usually visible on mammograms and can be
detected there and it's classified by
nuclear grading so that's important to
us because we want to make sure we're
giving good quality nuclear staining
with our hematoxylin and it can extend
into the duck so that's one thing to
consider but this slide is a grade one
and so that the features that make it a
grey one a grade one all right that the
nuclei are monotonous they look largely
alike there's not a variation in size or
shape and the size of the nuclei is 1.5
to 2 red blood cell diameters and
there's fine chromatin and an occasional
nucleoli but largely not in most of the
cells and so the second one we have here
is an intermediate grade and I apologize
i only have one magnification on this
one because a lot of people don't
photograph them and that I asked for
some help with my images here and and so
this the way that they determine what's
an intermediate grade is actually it's
not a great one and it's not a grade
three so and here we start to see some
different shape nuclei in ourselves we
see a few more nucleoli and some more
coarse chromatin and they're a little
bit bigger but not large not a lot
bigger than what we saw in a low grade
and so here's our high grade and it's
called a high grade comido comido is
referring to this area of necrosis over
here that we see often you know we would
if we BQ seeing this slide of the
district technologists we might think
that that was something that fell off or
we you know we had some sort of an
artifact there but it's actually
submitted corrosives and that happens
because when it's an aggressive cancer
and the cancer cells grow quickly some
of those cells don't get enough
nourishment and then those starved cells
start to die off and we get the areas of
necrosis and that's why this was called
a Kamino type but the things that
actually make it a grade 3 DG is just
for some interesting facts here they're
pleomorphic nuclei so we have all kinds
of different shapes and you can see
those over here and then we see some
coarse chromatin we see a lot more
nucleoli and they're larger the diameter
the size of the nuclei is a 2.5 red
blood cell diameters are larger in a
grade 3 and so if
we were looking at this slide I mean
what I'm mindful of is just how
important a good quality section is how
important it is for the pathologist to
be able to get to this level and to be
able to see into the nuclei and evaluate
the chromatin and a new clio I and to
have it all be in the same plane and
just be crisp and clear and that's why
our job is so important and why we want
to give them such a high quality nuclear
stained with good light of plasmic
background here's a picture of lobular
carcinoma inside too so that's we see
that the glands are expanded by a
uniform population of lobular cells and
you generally look the same and they're
all with and they're in the lobule and
it can be confusing because LCIS can
invade adducts and DC is can extend into
the lobules and so that's you know
something that's ologist are always
concerned with but again you can see
that nuclear staining is so important
and we have good eosin and our slides
here and because it is confusing that's
why we get in to the importance of IHC
and immunohistochemistry that's what the
next segment of this series will be when
that happens you will get to learn more
about just a different diagnostic test
that we have at our disposal now and
that make it easier for the pathologist
to distinguish exactly the distribution
of the cancers but it starts with us
with our good quality sections and
giving them a good baseline to start off
with their ordering of those tests and
that concludes my prepared comments and
I think we'll open up for questions now
thank you very much Jennifer that for
that presentation we're so happy to have
you be part of the cardinal health lab
exchange before we get started on our
question and answer session I'm going to
remind our audience how to submit their
questions the audience you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window
and we'll get to as many of those as we
can just give you a few minutes to find
that button and submit your questions
for Jennifer on her presentation on my
craw timing and special stains
okay we see we don't have any today for
Jennifer but we'd like to thank her for
being part of the Cardinal lab health
exchange and for our sponsor leica for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
October of this year and you'll receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to all of your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
thank you again for being part of our
presentation we'll see you next time
goodbye